like if we're talking in flavortown this
one is like it it's actually right the
[ __ ] out in the face when people think
of curry they think of curry and like in
Asia my knowledge of curry only expands
from Trinidadian dishes people try to
make it like an Indian thing outside of
the East Asian community I don't know
how common it is for people to consume
or know about Japanese curry so today we
will be trying different types of curry
from around the world so like in Indian
dishes or at least in my family I don't
want speak for everyone we don't really
say this type of curry will say you know
tikka masala or this type of dish so
it's definitely different from Japanese
curry slightly spicy it's slightly sweet
and the color is like such a brilliant
color and ever my family makes like
Caribbean dishes like the curry is like
a deeper color like a deeper Brown I've
had cardis like this before but this
isn't like necessarily what my family
would make the only name they go this
Curry's diverse yeah it's good
[Music]
this is what I'm talking about when I
said that curry this darker looks like
something my mom would make it home look
at the stained inch oh wow yeah yeah
that is so tender sure is a lot harder
er it almost feels like a stew it's also
drier which i think is interesting and
the juicers are like are almost like the
stuff like the sauce part of it this is
actually really good definitely expanded
my mind on what curry is and it is
delicious
I already is again
[Music]
so this is the kind of curry that I ate
growing up it's like sweet and tangy it
smells really good usually it has like a
lot of Tytos and carrots and meat and
stuff I like the consistency of it it's
really good it's not from summer on seem
right you can just normally have access
to this is definitely I totally
understand that it is nearly impossible
to describe curry as a type of food it
definitely expanded my mind out of Asia
a very defining it and understanding it
is really complex we're limited by the
language we have whereas you know these
authentic dishes have different words
for them in in their own regions with
like a larger breath than just what the
word curry to us can contain both
[Laughter]
[Music]